a particle moves along the x-axis so
that at any time t greater than or equal
to zero its velocity is given by v of t
is equal to negative t to the third
power plus t plus six t squared plus two
t
at what value of t does the particle
obtain its maximum acceleration
so we want to figure out when does it
obtain its maximum acceleration so let's
just review what they gave us they gave
us velocity as a function of time so
let's just remind ourselves if we have
let's say our position is a function of
time so let's say x of t is position as
a function of time then if we were to
take the derivative of that so
x prime
of t
well that's going to be the rate of
change of position with respect to time
or the velocity as a function of time
and if we were to take the derivative of
our velocity
then that's going to be the rate of
change of velocity with respect to time
well that's going to be acceleration as
a function of time so they give us
velocity so from velocity we can figure
out acceleration so let me just rewrite
that
so we know that v of t
is equal to negative
t to the third power plus six t squared
plus 2t
and so from that we can figure out
the acceleration
as a function of time which is just
going to be the derivative with respect
to t of the velocity
so just use the power rule a bunch so
that's going to be this is the third
power right there so negative
3 t squared
plus 2 times 6 is 12
t to the first
plus
2. so that's our acceleration as a
function of time
and we want to figure out when we obtain
our maximum acceleration and just
inspecting this acceleration function
here we see it's a quadratic it has a
second degree polynomial we have a
negative coefficient out in front of the
highest degree term in front of the quad
the second degree term so it is going to
be a downward opening parabola so it is
going to be a downward opening let me
draw it the same color so it is going to
have that general shape and so it will
indeed
take on it will indeed take on a
maximum value but how do we figure out
that maximum value well that maximum
value is going to happen when the
acceleration values when the when it's
when the slope of its tangent line is
equal to
when the slope of its tangent line is
equal to zero and we could also verify
that it is concave downwards at that
point using the second derivative test
by showing that the second derivative is
negative there so let's do that let's
look at the first and second derivatives
of our acceleration of our acceleration
function so
and i'll switch colors that one's
actually a little bit hard to see
so
the first derivative the rate of change
of acceleration
is going to be equal to
so this is negative 6 t
plus 12. now let's think about when does
this thing equal 0
well if we subtract 12 from both sides
we get negative 6t is equal to negative
12. divide both sides by negative 6 you
get t is equal to 2.
so
a couple of things you could just say
all right look i know that this is a
downward opening quadra a parabola right
over here have a negative coefficient on
my second degree term i know that the
slope of the tangent line here is zero
at t equals two so that's going to be my
maximum point or you could go a little
bit further you could take the second
derivative
you let's do that just for kicks so we
could take the second derivative of our
acceleration function
so this is going to be equal to
negative 6. right the derivative of
negative 60 is negative 6. the
derivative of constant is just 0. so
this thing the second derivative is
always negative so we are always
always
concave
concave
downward
downward and so by the second derivative
test at t equals 2 well at t equals 2
our second derivative our acceleration
function is going to be negative and so
we know that this is our maximum value
or max
at t
is equal to 2. so at what value of t
does the particle obtain its maximum
acceleration at t is equal to
at t is equal to 2.